yet another terrorist incident where the
weapon of choice is an automobile a BMW
rammed six French soldiers near their
barracks in Paris France
the vehicle in question took off after
the incident police were looking for the
driver later French TV reported that a
shootout took place on a motorway in
northern France and a suspect was
arrested a man in his late 30s believed
to be the perpetrator here so France has
been one of the countries hardest hit by
these sort of isolated incidents that we
have seen that relate to extremist
ideology although they are not
necessarily operationally connected and
that is what makes this very very
difficult France has been under a state
of emergency dating back to late 2015
and they've seen a number of attacks on
various security and law enforcement and
military forces there the individual
here told investigators that he wanted
to kill a soldier according to sources
close to the case the the we had another
incident in France that didn't even make
a blip but an 18 year old with a history
of psychological problems was arrested
over the weekend at the Eiffel Tower
after brandishing a knife and shouting
god is greatest'
in arabic and i've been talking about
this for a long time you can defeat the
Islamic state in terms of territory and
we are doing that and that was bound to
happen regardless of who was elected
president in November of 2016 I've been
talking about it since the presidency of
Barack Obama but that's different than
rooting out the ideology which exists in
isolated cells all over the world an ad
hoc law enforcement response to these
individual incidents that's a
non-starter preventive ly right there
are too many of these isolated
individuals you can't track them all you
can't prevent every incident you've got
the boss then do everything from the
Boston bombing brothers to San
Bernardino he has a very very long list
of these the nice truck attack long
story short we can't control and prevent
every single one of these incidents so
you have to target the creation of the
ideology but how do you do it right I
mean especially when you look at the
style of Paris
ataque that's becoming a trend here
because how can you regulate this I mean
I guess you could put up some sort of
barrier in between car traffic and foot
traffic or close down roads that have a
lot of pedestrians walking yeah I do it
everywhere you can't do it it's not like
you know guns where we can look into say
background checks or you know ammunition
restriction this is a lot more complex I
think I wish I had more specific ideas
what I do know is when we think about
how much we spend on weapons to fight
terrorism through bombing and missiles
we're spending way too much there we
will never use all the bombs and
missiles that we have stored and
purchased to stop terrorism and stop our
enemies around the world and that
doesn't do a thing to stop the
brainwashing of people into this
dangerous ideology it's difficult it's
concerning and I wish I had more
specific and concrete ideas here's where
I'll go to the audience
if you've read interesting ideas about
how to root out the ideology let me know
what articles or books I should be
reading to better inform myself because
I do a lot of reading on this and for
the most part what I'm finding is people
speaking in generalities
about rooting out the ideology and the
different role that everything ranging
from the Islamic texts to American
foreign policy have on the creation of
this ideology but I want to dig in as
concretely as possible as to what can be
done the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge of as little as $1 per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad